congressman Matt Gaetz represents
floridays also on the Judiciary
Committee and he joins us tonight
congressman I said I think it was on
Christmas Eve that instead of the NORAD
Santa Tracker NORAD ought to have an
impeachment articles tracker to see how
long it's taking to do the 73 feet from
Nancy Pelosi's office to the center I
think it's somewhere over the jungles of
New Guinea right now
is she actually gonna bring this thing
home and deliver it to McConnell and
Nancy Pelosi appears to be limping
through the back nine of the delivery of
the articles of impeachment and I think
for regular folks in this country it's
quite interesting to see an impeachment
with first no crime and no victim but
now no transmission of the articles
themselves listening to that montage you
had of the mainstream media giving Nancy
Pelosi a proverbial cat bath it just
reminds me that the rest of us ends up
stuck with the hairball with this sort
of circumstance where just weeks ago it
was Jerry Nadler and Eric's wall well
saying things like nothing could be more
urgent than this impeachment sois well
called it a crime spree in progress and
now Nancy Pelosi sort of holds the
articles of impeachment like some
demented you know non Santa Clause not
delivering the gifts to the children
it's a very strange to observe well it's
it's weird isn't it the president had a
good point in his tweet because
according to Jerrold Nadler donald trump
is a threat to national security and
needs to be removed from office so I
stick it in the bottom drawer and do
nothing about it well it demonstrates
that this was a political process from
the beginning we're about to turn over a
new year a new decade but we continue to
see the same politics just by new means
and what Democrats have done is they've
really cheapen the impeachment process -
any disagreement about the utilization
of presidential power or any
disagreement at maybe a president's
different type of approach to a
particular problem set all of a sudden
becomes impeachable now and when they
say in their court filings that they're
not done investigating articles of
impeachment I actually believe them
because they have no agenda for the
American people
so they
are substituting this process these
investigations and impeachment for
actual legislation that might improve
the lives of the people that were
elected to serve well doesn't that court
filing really give the game away because
it's one continuous investigation just
as Russia led into Ukraine and you know
maybe Trump was on the phone to some guy
in Tajikistan and we can put that on
hold for next week's impeachment a
basically they've been doing this
actually since before he was inaugurated
and it's worked only in that it's super
infused the Republican base for 2020 I
could tell you here in the state of
Florida our support for President Trump
is only intensified when we see these
efforts to delegitimize not only his
presidency but our political movement
for a positive America for a newfound
sense of populism in our country and now
I think you can look back to the time
directly after Robert Muller's testimony
where they wanted to impeach justice
Cavanaugh they wanted to impeach bill
Barr it's like they've got impeachment
fever and there's no cure how about we
turn over the calendar in 2020 and just
agree to put the American people first
in our country first not just have the
the revolving carnival of impeachment
with Nancy Pelosi as the ringleader that
that makes too much sense congressman
you know how it is with what one
impeachment is never enough you it's
like a box of chocolates you gotta have
a second or third thank you very much
for joining us tonight